moi je ce que j'aimerais le mieux ce
serait d'avoir un logement puisque je
nous sommes que dans deux pièces et nous
sommes 10 alors déjà rien qu'un logement
ce serait beaucoup plus agréable pour
nous capitaine je vous vois capitaine
des chasseurs ALP vous êtes habitué à la
neige que souhaitez-vous pour 1965 mais
ma fois d'abord du beau temps le plus
tôt possible pour passer les fêtes dans
de meilleures conditions pour pouvoir
circuler un peu et puis le maximum de
bonheur pour tout le monde si c'est
possible beaucoup de choses d'ailleurs
parce qu'en ce moment je vais voir mon
enfant qui est fr Chillou qui est très
malade alors déjà rien que ça je
voudrais un bon rétablissement autrement
une amélioration à tout point de vue sur
le travail le budget un peu surtout
pour parce que d'ailleurs moi ce que
j'aimerais le mieux ce serait d'avoir un
logement puisque je nous sommes que dans
deux pièces et nous sommes 10 alors déjà
rien qu'un logement ce serait beaucoup
plus agréable pour nous la baisse de
l'essence je souhaite que tout tout
aille pour le mieux qu'il y ait une
bonne circulation qu'on ait pas trop
d'accidents et pas de cette façon là
tout ira bien beaucoup de bonheur pour
pour tout le monde c'est tout ce qu'on
peut souhaiter voyez-vous et pour vous
en particulier ah pour moi en
particulier la réussite dans les
affaires si on peut dire la santé le
bonheur pour moi qui suis dans le
service urbain j'espère que l'année que
la circulation ira beaucoup mieux qu'il
y aura beaucoup
d'amélioration monsieur que
souhaitez-vous pour l'année 1965 bah du
beau temps mais encore bah je sais pas
moi bien des choses forcément par
exemple ben gagne pas mal de
compétitions en 60
5 je fais du cycle cross alors faudrait
bien en gagner quelquesunes quand même
c'est
çaêt rei au brevet qu'il y ait beaucoup
de permission pour moi que l'accueille
Vienne Vienne assez vite voyez pour moi
c'est un très beau jour parce que je
prends ma retraite cette année ah pour
moi une bonne santé pour toute la
famille bien entendu et pour tous mes
malades pour tous les gens que je soigne
je souhaite de pas avoir besoin de moi
cette année c'estàd que le mauvais temps
dure le moins longtemps possible parce
que c'est pas agréable de voyager quand
il fait froid évidemment hein et puis
alors ici à range on souhaite tous que
l'électrification Vienne au plus vite oh
d'abord une vie meilleure beaucoup
d'améliorations à tout point de vue
habitat puisque je travaille aux HLM et
puis je sais pas moi que tout le monde
soit heureux qu'on découvre beaucoup de
choses au point de vue médecine
et je sais pas moi que tout le monde
tout ce que tout le monde peut souhaiter
monsieur quel veux formez-vous pour 1965
je souhaite de tout mon cœur un beau
soleil pour l'année 65 un beau soleil
qui chauffe la brtin tout entière oh
comme je suis mariée jeis bien un
enfant un petit garçon de préférence et
qui REM à mon mari beaucoup
d'enfants du bon temps pour
commencer bons je sais pas la prospérité
tout ce que vous voulez tout ce qu'il a
de bon des beau programmes à la
télévision de bon résultat à l'école
meilleur que cette
année que tout se passe bien bien pour
les en politique ailleurs il faudrait je
sais pas que tout le monde s'entende
quoi dans tous les peuples partout une
année aussi bonne que cette année au
moins à tout point de vue même du point
de vue politique la paix dans le monde
la paix dans T les peuples c'est c'est
tout monsieur ce que vous souhaitez pas
mal les
[Musique]
G